[Music]  like mother like daughter  Yolanda Hadid rocking the same bikini as  daughter Bella did years ago my sister's  my best friend my mom's our best friend  age ain't nothing but a number for  Yolanda the 54 year old is currently  living her best tropical vacation life  jumping high in this pic while showing  off her toned body in a knitted bikini  quote not perfect but happy vans were  quick to notice that 21 year old Bella  posed in the same sheet two-piece in  2016 when she was just 19 and this isn't  the first time they've shared styles  earlier this year Yolanda got candid  about learning from her model daughters  I'm from the old generation like it was  a very different time like they've  taught me about social media and and all  that kind of stuff but when it comes to  you know the values of work ethic and  all that you know they trust my my input  in that  [Music]